time for the verizon speed round brought
to you by verizon 5g all right peter
let's get into it and we're talking now
about
excuse me we're talking now about
coaching vacancies who do you think is
the first team to hire a coach and who
do you think the first coach hired will
be
um i think the first team to hire a
coach
is is probably going to be the atlanta
falcons
and uh as for who they're going to hire
i don't have a great feel i think that
my biggest feel i think there's going to
be a bit of a race
i
if if the atlanta falcons hire let's say
terry fontenot of the saints as their gm
and i know they like terry fontenot but
if they hire him
i mean my gut feeling is he's gonna cast
a wide net for the people that he knows
and that the falcons know and in my
opinion
i think one of the guys they're gonna be
very interested in is arthur smith
uh because i think arthur smith has
become a favorite and not just because
he really knows offense i think people
look at his history and look at his
connection to joe gibbs when he was on
that washington staff learning from
gibbs and bugle and all the old classic
washington coaches
just my absolute gut feeling especially
if they settle on let's say terry
fontenot
the the arthur smith angle is
fascinating to me because
the last thing he needs to worry about
is making huge money for a lot of these
guys
it's the culmination of a career in
football right and a lot of these guys
come from nothing they have an obsession
they work at it and they work at it and
they work at it i mean i'm here in coal
mining country we've we've given rise to
nick saban rich rodriguez jimbo fisher
this is your way out and you and you
climb to the top of the mountain
financially arthur smith born on the top
of the mountain his dad founded fedex
yeah so he can wait
he can be selective he doesn't need to
say
i've reached my pot of gold he already
has the pot of gold
his decision
is going to be driven by
factors
that while present for other coaching
candidates
they're not going to have to box out
this this urgency to go get paid you
know i think sometimes guys will take
jobs with bad teams just because they
want to get that big contract arthur
smith is a guy who who won't have that
on the table and it may make him more
selective peter about where he goes for
his first nfl head coaching job
but you you also have to consider the
fact that
sometimes you're the hot guy
and then look i don't expect this to
happen but tennessee goes seven and nine
next year all of a sudden arthur smith's
not the hot guy
and so
sometimes your window is short look at
josh mcdaniels you don't hear him
mention for many of these jobs at all
now
and you know look we could discuss josh
mcdaniels i'm sure for an entire segment
but the point is sometimes you have to
strike while the iron's hot i'm not
saying the iron will never be hotter for
arthur smith
but the iron's pretty hot right now and
you know i think he has to survey the
landscape
and in surveying the landscape he has to
decide only he's going to know he and
his agent are going to be able to
understand
you know if if some team is leaning
toward let's say robert sala this team
is leaning toward eric b enemy he said
listen i want to get one of these
musical chairs before the music stops
i think the first guy hired is going to
be urban meyer by the jacksonville
jaguars nfl media reported that he is
meeting with the jaguars today he's been
talking way too much to people
about
potential coaching staff additions and
also general managers that meyer would
hire if he takes the job
if the meeting with shaud khan goes well
and the money is in the range where it
needs to be and i was told earlier this
week it's 12 million a year and then
there was a report saying that that's
false or something like that well that
means he ain't getting 12 million a year
will he take whatever he can get
uh
we'll see but but i think there's a
chance if everything works out
financially and just fit and feel and
he's ready to do it he could be the
first one to go let's continue through
the speed round brought to you by can i
ask you one thing mike before we move on
mike i want to ask you one thing before
we move on what do you think of my
skepticism about urban meyer
skepticism born of
uh
quitting football at age quitting
coaching at age 45 46 and 54. three
different times
uh never having a losing season at any
level of college football and knowing
that you know this is a team that's won
25 percent of its games over the last
three years
and i would say with i'd say finally
what makes him different
from nick saban in miami
where he might be two years into it or
three years into it even though he's got
his quarterback it's been proven over
the years that even a quarterback is
you're not going to start winning
immediately how's he going to take
losing
and is he going to get sick of it at
some point sooner than jacksonville
might think
when the reports first emerged that
multiple teams were doing their homework
on urban meyer i found a podcast
involving chris spielman now
special adviser to lions owner sheila
fordham
and spielman was talking about
meyer's angst and his torment
the last year at ohio state when he fell
to his knees and people were saying it's
health issues
and i wrote an item and quoted
extensively what spielman had to say and
i think reading between the lines
i think spielman understands
that
urban meyer will not be able to handle
it in the nfl he won't be able to handle
the agony of defeat he won't be able to
handle the torment and and the
frustration
and everything that goes along with
dealing with being the coach of a team
that isn't dominant
that that and that's why
i think
we haven't heard anything about urban
meyer possibly coaching the lines you
know at first it was like hey jaguars
lions jaguars lions the last week and a
half it's just jaguars jaguars jaguars i
think chris spielman knows
that that it's probably not good for
urban meyer's psychological well-being
to be an nfl head coach because if you
get tormented as a spy
why might the jaguars hire him
do they not know this
do they not look at his resume
listen peter the thing i love the most
about the national football league
beyond the actual playing of the games
the intrigue and the
the the the the the the palace drama
you've got owners of these franchises
who know a hell of a lot less than you
or i do about how it all works
and now
that team for 10 years well but do they
care do they care do they do they do
they
i mean do you know they
they they know best
they know best
they know what's right for their team
and they know what's right for their
business and frankly peter look
maybe at this point in the overall life
of the jacksonville jaguars it means
more to have urban meyer and trevor
lawrence than it does to actually become
a team that wins 12 games a season or 13
games a season you know you've tried a
bunch of other different things let's
try this let's fill our stadium let's
sell tickets let's become more
financially viable than we've been at
least for a couple of years and if it
doesn't work it doesn't work we move on
to the next guy so i think there's
alright here's my two points about that
all right here's here's my two points
about that there's an old saying
in coach chasing and that is
winning the press conference you know
some owners really want to win the press
conference okay
who
cares
really who cares secondly peter are
there here's who cares right here's who
cares
union
yeah
go ahead go ahead
i'll let you know are there people
writing letters to the florida times
union oh my god give us urban meyer oh
he's going to come and be a savior
please please urban meyer i mean are the
fans demanding it
well i guess my point is this they do
want to win the press conference the
owners want to win the press conference
because winning the press conference
means selling tickets generating
excitement generating coverage selling
jerseys all the things that go along
with making money at the core these are
32 for-profit businesses and they they
don't
wear that on their sleeves
you don't sell jerseys on the head coach
well i know but you but if if you get a
head coach that gets people excited then
that sells jerseys you're going to sell
jerseys of trevor lawrence it's the
combination of the two anyway we got
river lawrence would sell jerseys if the
head coach
was little orphan you or me or me
uh all right who's the favorite to land
eric the enemy we talked about the
texans not being interested the other
five openings have interest in him where
does he go
i mean
you know if i had to guess this is an
absolute guess i would guess the
chargers
because the chargers want a guy
who knows everything
about uh the the the quarterback and the
head coach of their new arch rivals and
the team they have to beat for the next
decade andy reid and patrick mahomes
give me uh
you know give me the
chargers and eric b enemy
hey in my view that's the most
attractive opening because you have a
quarterback there who has proven
already that he's a great quarterback
and uh and they've got a lot of great
players and i i don't feel like they're
that far away from being a truly
competitive and contending team which
team and i think i know the answer to
this based upon our prior discussion in
the show about desean watson which team
is most likely to make a head scratching
higher
houston i don't even know what it'll be
but
unless they get pressured now
heavily heavily pressured into going
after eric b enemy
i think they're going to make a head
scratching higher and i don't even know
who it is
surprise name to look out for as the
pieces begin to fall into place
well
i would say that a surprise name to look
out for uh is somebody who we really
don't know yet somebody who has got to
emerge
after these rounds of the playoffs i
mean i i'm not even i i don't even know
who i would say other than i've got two
on my list
one is brian schottenheimer uh because i
think he's getting more and more respect
around the league and the other one even
though he's gotten some love is brandon
staley i think brandon staley would be
my little outsider's view of a guy who's
got the best chance to get a head
coaching job in this league
isn't it amazing
that dennis allen the saints defensive
coordinator can't get a sniff isn't that
amazing to you
you know the whole new orleans thing is
amazing to me
you know carmichael
campbell on offense
you know dennis allen on defense the two
great guys in their front office jeff
ireland terry fontenot
it's almost like
you know sean payton lords above all and
also mickey loomis obviously but
everybody just looks at them as the sean
payton saints and you know mickey loomis
sort of being the stage manager of this
team and setting the stage for
everything good that happens
and i'll just tell you you know i've had
some discussions over the last couple of
years with people at organization who
asked the same question that you just
asked
how in the world
can't like
dan campbell and pete carmichael even
get the first base
in the interview process and you
mentioned dennis allen after the job of
that defense i agree
for me the surprise name to look out for
is marvin lewis even though he's on the
radar screen i don't think anyone
believes he's being taken seriously as a
candidate anywhere the guy was with the
bengals for an extended period of time
he took him to the playoffs nine times
he thrived amid the dysfunction that is
inherent to that organization when it
comes to
being extremely careful with money
and he's a stabilizing force the jets
interviewed him yesterday and jets fans
were like oh give me a break no give me
a break this guy's better than anyone
you've had since rex ryan and he's
probably better than rex ryan peter
i agree mike i think i think marvin
lewis is an underrated guy in this
process in my opinion when i look at him
i look at him with the two words that
you just mentioned stabilizing force he
wouldn't be a popular hire but i think
he'd be a good hire
all right that was the speed round
brought to you by verizon 5g built right
when we return our wild card excuse me
super wild card edition of the show me
something draft we'll be back with more
right after this
brought to you by verizon 5g built right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports